اذا لم تبدا اصوات القصف التركيه على
مناطق الفصائل الكرديه في شمال سوريا منذ
اكثر من اسبوع عبر مدافع الهاوزر
والطائرات الحربيه ولا تزال تركيا تؤكد
انها ستنفذ عمليه التوهل البري اليوم يقول
مسؤول تركي ان الجيش لا يحتاج الا لايام
قليله ليكون جاهزا للعمليه الكبرى وسيكون
في انتظار القرار السياسي مسؤولون اتراك
قالوا ان قوات المعارضه السوريه التي
تتحالف مع انقره اصبحت مستعده ايضا لنفس
المعركه في انتظار الاوامر يصف المسؤولون
الاتراك العمليه البريه بانها حتميه وذلك
لربط المناطق التي دخلت تحت سيطره تركيا
والمعارضه التابعه لها خلال عمليات 2000
2016 الى ان تركيا ستتجه لاستهداف مناطق
منبج وعين العرب وتل رفعت في عملياتها
المرتقبه
امريكا كانت ابلغت تركيا بان لديها مخاوف
بالغه من ان يؤدي التصعيد العسكري الى
التاثير على مواجهه تنظيم داعش ايضا كانت
حذرت روسيا من شن عمليه تركيه من شانها ان
تزعزع الاستقرار ذلك رغم وصفها لمخاوف
تركيا بالمشروعه اما انقر فتقول انها
تتمسك بما تصفه بحقها في حمايه نفسها
وانها تبقي على خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه
سياسيا جيدا من اجل مواجهه عقبات اي قرار
فهي تواصل ماده حبال الود مع نظام السوري
منذ فتره الرئيس التركي اكد مجددا ان
الامور قد تعود الى نصابها مع سوريا وجدد
ما يقوله منذ اسابيع انه قد يلتقي الاسد
فلا خصومه دائمه في السياسه
[موسيقى]
بدات هذه الازمه بعد تفجير اسطنبول الذي
اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى قبل اسبوعين
وتهمت انقره واحداث حمايه الشعب الكرديه
في الهجوم رغم نفي الاخيره اليوم نشر
الامن التركي صوره احد عناصر حمايه وحدات
حمايه الشعب وقال انه احد المتورطين في
تفجير اسطنبول ويتم البحث عنه يضيف الامن
التركي ان عمليه التخطيط تمت في مدينه عين
العرب شمال سوريا وهي احدى المدن
المستهدفه في العمليه التي تريد تركيا ومع
تاكيد تركيا على ضروره العمليه العسكريه
يرى النازحون السوريون شمال البلاد ان
حياتهم اصبحت اشبه بالمستحيله
وين الروح لا تركيا تستقبلنا لا دول برا
بتستخدمنا
وضرب هذا ما يعني تفائل نسوان عيال ارواح
يعني ما تقدر العيله بالليل بالنهار
ناجحين صار لنا عشر سنين نازحين عم نتحول
من منطقه المنطقه
حدود تركيا